what is embeddings with the rise of llms
why is it becoming important to
understand how they work
in traditional I.T systems most data is
organized as tabular data using simple
keywords and labels and databases and
search engines
in contrast AI power Services arrange
data into a simple data structure known
as embeddings
once trained with specific content like
text images or any content AI creates a
space called embedding space which is
essentially a map of Economist meaning
AI can identify the location of each
content on the map that's what embedding
is
[Music]
and AI can put content with similar
meanings closely together in the space
the real embedding space looks like this
here you can see the three million
images are sorted by their meaning at
human level precision
embeddings is the key technology for
Google search YouTube and so on to find
highly relevant contents
in summary AI can represent various
contents with embeddings enables the
next gen user experience
to learn more please check the resources
on the comment